[Música]
tragedia en Honduras al menos 41
reclusas murieron en el interior de una
cárcel tras una aparente enfrentamiento
entre pandillas la presidenta Xiomara
Castro pidió a las autoridades de
seguridad rendir cuentas por lo sucedido
en Colombia gran revés a la reforma
laboral del presidente Gustavo Petro el
proyecto no pudo ser debatido por falta
de cuero ni el mandatario afirma que
esto hunde su proyecto de ley mientras
en las calles del país miles de personas
protestaron contra los planes del
gobierno
sigue las movilizaciones en la provincia
de Jujuy en Argentina por la reforma
constitucional local que prohíbe
distintos tipos de protestas
manifestantes y policías protagonizaron
enfrentamientos que dejaron varias
personas heridas
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias del continente americano en 24
los saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos
en Honduras las autoridades han
confirmado la muerte de al menos 41
reclusas durante un presunto
enfrentamiento entre pandillas en la
cárcel femenina adaptación social
conocida como cefas por sus siglas el
reporte es que 25 de ellas murieron
calcinadas y otras 16 acribilladas la
presidenta Xiomara Castro calificó la
situación como negligencia mientras que
la viceministra de seguridad ordenó la
intervención inmediata de la prisión y
culpó al crimen organizado por lo
sucedido
sin duda alguna lo ocurrido hoy en este
momento lamentable es producto de un
ataque directo del crimen organizado
contra las acciones que deliberadamente
están realizando contra la criminalidad
organizada en Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro sostuvo que se hundió la
reforma laboral el proyecto no logró el
quorum requerido para que el congreso lo
votara el mandatario reaccionó en
Twitter y calificó el hecho como una
cooptación del legislativo
el hundimiento de la reforma laboral es
muy grave demuestra que la voluntad de
paz y de pacto social no existe en el
poder económico Dueños del capital y de
los medios lograron cooptar el congreso
en contra de la dignidad del pueblo
trabajador creen que las ganancias salen
de la esclavitud las largas jornadas y
la completa inestabilidad laboral el
gobierno del cambio no abandonará los
intereses de la trabajadora y el
trabajador Esto ocurrió el mismo día en
que los opositores organizaron una
marcha en contra de los proyectos de ley
bandera del gobierno Petro las reformas
al trabajo a la salud y a las pensiones
menos de dos semanas antes Los
Seguidores del presidente salieron a las
calles a apoyarlo el informe es de
Samuel Salgado
[Aplausos]
la oposición al gobierno de Gustavo
Petro midió su fuerza en las calles en
Bogotá unas 5.000 personas participaron
en la denominada marcha de la mayoría
según datos de las autoridades locales
la principal Consigna no más Petro y
fuera Petro una señal del de rechazo de
ciertos sectores de la oposición no solo
a las políticas gubernamentales sino la
figura del presidente para defender la
democracia y la libertad para defender
la independencia de poder en las
instituciones que hoy están en riesgo
por cuenta del escándalo que protagoniza
Gustavo Petro y su familia y el círculo
cercano esta jornada de protestas anti
gubernamentales la segunda más grande en
menos de un año llega en un momento de
crisis política para Gustavo Petro las
denuncias de medios locales sobre
presunta corrupción en la financiación
de su campaña presidencial así como
escándalos en su círculo cercano de
gobierno afectaron la imagen del
mandatario de izquierda según sondeos un
nuevo capítulo de la crisis sucedió Este
martes luego de que el poder legislativo
tumbara la reforma laboral una de las
propuestas clave del proyecto del cambio
parece que las reformas son mal
planeados mal pensadas inconvenientes
para el país pero lo peor de todo me
parece rendirle culto a todos los billos
y escudarse en narcotraficantes en
guerrilleros los de las en un encuentro
con las fuerzas militares el presidente
de Colombia Se pronunció sobre las
protestas Esa es la expresión del
talante democrático
el que aquí se puedan expresar como
quieran siempre que se respeten los
derechos
contra el mismo gobierno y no pase nada
tanto la oposición como el oficialismo
calientan motores para las elecciones
locales que tendrán lugar en octubre
a cinco días de las elecciones generales
en Guatemala el tribunal supremo
electoral terminó de distribuir el
mobiliario de los puntos de votación así
lo aseguró el tc en su cuenta de Twitter
por lo que ya están listas las mesas y
las cajas en las urnas por otro lado la
Organización de Estados Americanos fue a
desplegó este martes una misión de
observación que acompañará a los
comicios del 25 de junio ese día 9,3
millones de personas están llamadas a
votar por el presidente el congreso el
parlamento centroamericano y alcaldes
siguen las manifestaciones en Argentina
por la aprobación de la Reforma a la
Constitución provincial de Jujuy que
restringe el derecho a la protesta y
limita los derechos de las comunidades
indígenas según la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos se
registraron varios manifestantes heridos
por el uso excesivo de la fuerza
policial y 25 personas fueron detenidas
entre ellas periodistas ampliamos en el
informe de Samuel Salgado
represión policial
vehículos incendiados y Furia en las
calles de San Salvador de Jujuy en el
norte de Argentina una reforma a la
Constitución provincial promovida por el
gobernador y aprobada de madrugada del
pasado viernes provocó las
manifestaciones
la medida prohíbe los cortes de calles
así como toda perturbación al derecho a
la libre circulación de las personas y
la ocupación indebida de edificios
públicos algo que los manifestantes
califican como una violación al derecho
de la protesta la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos cidh
se mostró preocupada
la cidh llama al Estado a respetar el
derecho a la libertad de expresión los
estándares interamericanos del uso de la
fuerza y a llevar a cabo un proceso de
diálogo efectivo inclusivo e
intercultural en que se respeta los
derechos sindicales y de los pueblos
originarios pero el gobernador de Jujuy
no retrocede y responsabiliza el
gobierno nacional por la extrema
violencia que se está dando en la
provincia repudio y hago un llamado a
todos los argentinos a repudiar lo que
está haciendo el kirchnerismo y el
frente de izquierda en Jujuy el
presidente Alberto Fernández le
respondió al gobernador usted es el
único responsable de haber llevado a
nuestra querida provincia de Jujuy a
esta situación límite tratando de
imponer una reforma constitucional que
no respeta la Constitución nacional esta
disputa entre el gobernador de Jujuy
posible candidato presidencial de
derechas y el kirchnerismo agudiza el
debate político de Cara a las elecciones
de octubre
en otras noticias el presidente Joe
biden se pronunció brevemente sobre su
hijo Hunter biden quien llegó hoy a un
acuerdo con los fiscales para declararse
culpable de tres delitos menores por no
haber pagado el impuesto Federal sobre
la renta y por poseer un arma de manera
ilegal la decisión le evitaría un
eventual ingreso a prisión esto Dijo el
mandatario cuando usted le preguntó al
respecto
señor presidente ha hablado con su hijo
hoy
señor presidente alguna reacción a su
declaración de culpabilidad
estoy muy orgulloso de mi
este 20 de junio se conmemoró el Día
Mundial de los refugiados Y al igual que
en varios lugares del planeta en América
Latina también hubo marchas aunque esta
es la región con menos cantidad de
personas que piden asilo y con
refugiados en sus territorios las
situaciones que enfrentan son difíciles
Max Pérez Gallardo nos cuenta
los refugiados también se movilizan por
América Latina en el marco del día para
conmemorar el desplazamiento en el mundo
un grupo de organizaciones civiles y más
de 400 solicitantes de Refugio salieron
a las calles de Tapachula al sur de
México para visibilizar su condición
migratoria un encuentro Sin fronteras
como se denominó la protesta tuvo lugar
cuando se reporta una cifra récord de
solicitudes de asilo de personas
desplazadas principalmente desde
Centroamérica
más de 250.000 personas que han
solicitado asilo en México
esto implica Pues sí hay mucha presión
Porque el 70% de las solicitudes
prácticamente se hace aquí en Tapachula
y en Palenque por ejemplo México es país
de tránsito y destino para miles de
personas que huyen de la violencia la
represión política y la inestabilidad
económica que azota países como Honduras
Guatemala El Salvador y Nicaragua sobre
este último el colectivo nunca más ong
nicaragüense encargada de documentar
violaciones a los derechos humanos en el
país centroamericano informó que desde
las protestas contra el presidente
Daniel Ortega en abril de 2018 el país
ha experimentado El Éxodo humano más
grande de su historia
[Música]
entre abril de 2018 y diciembre de 2022
al menos
462.810 personas nicaragüenses se habían
desplazado forzadamente fuera del país y
en su mayoría solicitaron formalmente
alguna categoría de protección
internacional en Estados Unidos Costa
Rica México y España
a junio de 2023 serían más de 600.000
los que salieron de Nicaragua en busca
de protección según Naciones Unidas
existen unos 20 millones de desplazados
en América Latina una condición
invisibilizada en la región pero que hoy
se encuentra más latente que nunca
hasta que es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]